sometimes things are just so cute you
have to you have to share it and post it
well northwest might think otherwise
while appearing on the today show kim
kardashian says her daughter north calls
her out for posting certain things
online sometimes north will see me
scrolling on my phone and say oh you
posted that of me
you know singing with my friends or
whatever i'll post and you know so
you learn boundaries kim didn't exactly
say which clip north called her out on
but there's plenty of moments that come
to mind
hi everyone in california it's kim
kardashian west and i just wanted to
talk to you and northwest
we have a feeling nine-year-old north
didn't keep quiet about this car karaoke
session belting out disney classics
[Music]
i mean we're with kim here some things
are too cute not to share even when the
joke's on you
okay i'm going to open it and show you
guys
why do i talk different from what when
for my videos i'm the same human being i
don't talk different
north is known for mocking kim online
keeping her mom on her toes and us
entertained how cute is olivia rodrigo
you guys i can't wait for her album you
guys know i love driver's license
yes i do i listen to it all the time no
surprise where north gets it from at
least that's what kim told us before she
definitely has kanye's outgoing
personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or
who it might offend the scams founder
also gets candid about how she manages
her kids social media presence they
don't really have social media or
anything like that on their ipads we go
with ipads um my daughter north has a
phone
that um i think her dad and i decided to
get it for her for christmas and
just to communicate with us but it just
has wi-fi she has games on it and fun
creative things but not really any
social media apps or anything i i don't
even know when that conversation is
going to happen i'm not ready for that
one yet we're still you know too young
for that
but it's something her estranged husband
kanye west has been vocal about pleading
with kim about not allowing north to
post on tick tock
i'm in love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
has a
private tick tock account so we we do
lots of tick tocks together she puts
them in drafts
she's not allowed to post them but we
have lots of tick tocks still kim keeps
north's content coming on their joint
tick tock and we aren't complaining
[Music]
kim also reveals she changed over the
years since having kids and is
cherishing private moments more these
days i love to share with the world i've
always been that person and i still do
but just kind of on my own terms you
know i love filming our new show and i
kind of give it all there seems like the
whole family agrees kim's sister chloe
told et back in april how they plan to
have boundaries on what they share on
the hulu show i think for every sister
we have different boundary levels and we
all try to respect that
[Music]
you